[Music]
so you guys have heard of Fenty savage
x20 Rihanna's brand
Rihanna's branch what do they do
intimate apparel is a lingerie
yeah the savage ex venti is the Lunger
do they have the panties that aren't
like open I don't know I don't mean
crotchless panties like Pat it's like
how do you use that on regular life it's
made for sense opposed to it there's a
whole world is yeah luxury you don't
really wear it for like that's fancy but
don't you want to hold where the [ __ ]
is but she had the sickest show I should
put on a show that was tight they should
make a zipper one day I'm sure they have
it but maybe that doesn't work oh yeah
skin just a rubbing they're rubbing
against you have a [ __ ] or something
mouse I'm off with the guy oh good it's
like teeth yeah okay the Venus flytrap
he was about the way I think so either
by the way by the way you played it the
crustless of your [ __ ] do you see no I
loved it no no kiss my ass no [ __ ] that
I'm reviewing your proposed by ass both
of you guys you kiss my ass
what we no no no we're all right some
people did it too much and then they had
to laugh scandal this is happening
around
Rihanna's brand oh no okay so social
status right now makes people really
liked it have you guys heard of truth in
advertising at Cornell yes that's the
main [ __ ] crooks of of a lot of
advertising yes so they are marketing
watchdog and they published a report
that criticized
savage xfinty for not making its
membership terms more prominent and they
went as far as to say that the company
has engaged in deceptive marketing and
illegal business practices to get their
customers to enroll into a 49.95 per
month program without them knowing about
it
okay that means well that's not the
truth
I heard of it's more of a principle what
oh yeah well it's a custom consumer
advocacy group that's what truth in
advertising is so what do they do wrong
okay so they're saying here here's some
examples so if you go shopping on their
website cute they have this robe right
this is an example and it says here the
price and it's 32 dollars but if you're
not really paying attention
you would miss the fact that in this
corner here it says like it when it's
grayed out what the hell's a mouse when
it's grayed out
it shows regular price is $82.00 it's
very patient VIP is 64 but then you get
an additional discount so it gets a
little confusing so once you try to add
it to your cart automatically it adds
the membership the monthly membership
and if you're not paying attention you
don't even realize that you're signing
up for this [ __ ] what is that 49.95 come
on put you into a subscription service
yes I just keep saying you underwear no
it's not that happening is you're in
this program let's go get discounts you
get discounts for the products if you're
a member so you pay the membership for
the discounts exactly it's a hidden
Costco yeah it is because they're not
being super obvious with that couldn't
be more obvious about it like you can
walk through the door without a cart
nothing very serious about it I love
that me too so there's riffraff out
exactly example they walk right in no I
tried only if you run fast only can run
in fast yeah they can't check out you're
coming with a group okay of your own
race anyway so here's another example of
their deceptive practices that truth in
advertising is claiming so here's an
example of their Instagram story so
right here it says like v-day is coming
and it says $25 set and then an $81
value and then really really really
small what
come on guys new extra VIP exclusive
yeah Wow
so yes you can't even get it unless
you're part of the VIP so which is why
if you scroll up and then you get it
they automatically put that VIP member
and slap you with it exactly the shady
[ __ ] that's happening rihanna [ __ ] this
is her company yes did we want to have
something to say about this not that I
know of yet but there who's the shady
[ __ ] that did this I don't know she has
people on her something Rihanna's like
you know what's a good idea go real
small so small here's the other thing it
seems to be a common practice so have
you ever heard of fabletics yes
so fabletics it has close ties to Kate
Hudson the actress and so they also have
a similar subscription model where you
become a member and then you get a
discounted price for the whatever items
you want to buy they are more obvious
about it like they're more like look for
a face yeah it's up front it's not shady
because I'm not hiding anything yes but
then that's why that's why true truth
and advertising are saying like y'all
are being [ __ ] Shady for ravage Savage
I expensive that was shady for sure no I
bring you are hiding something and it's
but it's not worst I mean you know it's
no more shady than [ __ ] car ad with
like if you have the right [ __ ]
credit you're getting the sickest price
yeah we're like a timeshare
unfortunately not to be too cynical but
they put out this car and then they'll
be like this crazy ass deal and you look
at the bottom you know the like there's
only two at this offer yeah right and
you want to go that always hold those
two so now you have to pay this one or
Black Friday they do that [ __ ] they're
like hey it's a doorbuster deal there's
four per store you know guess what
there's [ __ ] 400 people in line yeah
you know what I like when I go to the
gym like a commercial gym and it's
always a last day sale every day is the
last day every day every day is a
blowout last day sale it's an anthem on
end of the month sale on the 10th yep
Victoria's Secret has three semi annual
sales yes right but these cells are my
chocolate technically this semiannual
little bit is that a Tremec Wayne you
you sound like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
Starbucks size cup I know it's a trim I
can I get it to try my latte
yeah do we like Victoria's Secret
anymore it's over right yeah
what's the new new then talk about the
paint thing though okay sorry about
their perfumes no it's never been good
about their socks I hate their
prostitute I think the pink line save
Victoria Secret for a certain amount of
time it did yeah and then to the younger
generation - yeah is there still
Frederick's of Hollywood and got rid of
those it calls most of those all you
really have are hustlers and they're not
everywhere never Larry Flynt's hustling
no I know that but that's like going to
the Halloween store to get lingerie
that's like going to the Halloween store
to get those sex costumes they said they
sell vibrators and stuff - is it so
dispensers for that [ __ ] - Bob rate is
not the biggest range they're whole
[ __ ] brand it's not like Hollywood I
mean a Larry Flynt hustla they have like
a whole set like it's literally from
that wall to that wall they got a drill
dough - what's a drill though alarm1
crazy it was one there's the one I don't
think it was a car loan
she's the drill dough in the car got
excited what is a drill does the drill
dough is a dildo that's attached to a
power drill I see and it's literally
like it's the point yeah drill down and
then what do you do what where's the
pleasure when it's spinning I don't know
I haven't seen it in action but I was in
Las Vegas at a sex store and it said
bajar the drool though and it was a
power drill with a dildo attached to it
I was like I hope it goes in and now
maybe if you had a dildo
screw then it's pretty happy though
jackhammer like I knew those muscles are
gonna get ya know that might feel good
huh okay so I can't imagine that
representatives from savage X fancy they
said this savage expensi believes it is
compliant with customer what the heck
the page just refreshed and I lost my
spot that I was reading no problem we
have no internet here hold on where did
it go take a bite okay
savage expensi believes it is compliant
with consumer protection laws and has
not received any inquiries from the FTC
savage expensi received this complaint
from truth and advertising tina at the
same time as the press and while we
wouldn't typically issue a public
response we are because these
accusations are false and based on
misconceptions of our business we are
misconception Tommy we're proud of our
flexible membership program because it
allows us to offer unparalleled quality
and value to our club hi I'm a big
company companies don't get flexibility
from the FTC we especially never pay the
FTC or officials from the FTC or their
family members to help us get compliance
I did really quick they also did
reference the fact that they Savage X
fancies net promoter score of 77 and an
A rating with the BBB come on man 77 in
Asian household that's a beating but why
is it a 77 MMA explain not actually if
it's anything under 98% or 99% it's a
beating it wasn't a really a 77 BBB no
that's the Net Promoter Score which I
don't know what that means it sounds bad
and they could be doing better
well maybe it's not 77 percent it's just
77 points let me Google this [ __ ] no
you'll have this matter well what
matters is the joke was funny which was
what it was earlier the beating the
beating I won't explain the joke the
drill no no the joke was funny but yeah
I think point out that it was fun wait
what part was but me but I was the joke
to point it out there was what if she
was joking tune calling you not funny
Oh
oh yeah that's a good one I'm gonna
build your [ __ ] pool with a drill
okay my dog's a [ __ ] bite you
oh my god you want me to google drill
down you think I'm a [ __ ] lying sack
of [ __ ] questioning my authority you
don't want to fight you may be overly
believe in doing okay well you know she
don't want you to see what a drill dough
looks like yes that's a drill doh okay
it says gildo you yes skeptical my pager
are you gonna trust that kind of that
pool way I pull me I don't know but it
might make me hot oh [ __ ] okay that's
not what I want who can fit a big dick
like that oh my god how big you think
that thing is my [ __ ] pool Cappy
that's a drilled oh man are you that big
I heard you got a big game okay he
always shied away from me let's make him
feel like Kyle confirm can you go to
just big babies not ready for that
well they come ready why is it so
intimate to you it's not intimate it's I
mean the weight side its engorged right
that's it yeah
boy wait for that engorged right let's
see if you can engorge it right now no I
think this is why I only come once a
month you've actually been here twice
this one
oh no you're here like in the moment I
came twice in January are we ready for
this alright to hear that but also
you've been here twice in a month is
ready to end yeah let's go ahead okay
should I end it on my joke what joke
[Music]